[Musique]
nous nous reverrons
je ne sais pas où
je ne sais pas quand
mais je sais que
nous nous reverrons
un jour ensoleillé
bonjour je suis johnny knoxville bienvenue à
jackie
trois
deux
un
[Applaudissements
] beaucoup de gens demandent quoi  est-ce que le crétin sera
comme une fois que nous serons plus âgés, eh bien,
plus vous pédalerez vite sur votre vélo,
plus vite la main de l'autre gars reculera,
vous avez dit que ça n'allait pas ressembler à
quoi que ce soit, les commotions cérébrales ne sont pas géniales mais
tant que vous  les avoir avant d'avoir 50 ans
c'est cool et knoxville a 49 ans
donc on va bien
et devinez ce que nous sommes ici
[Applaudissements]
nous avons des gagnants et nous avons steve
un tas de scientifiques de la nasa,
qu'avez-vous fait pour qu'eric
échoue à se préparer, préparez-vous à échouer,
vous avez toujours ces dents d'un million de dollars,
c'est sûr
que non  préparez-vous à l'échec sur
celui-ci aaron s'il vous plaît détendez-vous je suis pris au piège
et vous mettez du miel sur moi  e et
saumon
oh mon dieu
toi